Good morning, John.
Today we're going to be doing something a
little bit different.
I'm gonna be holding a debate here in my house
around the topic of net neutrality, featuring
me, an internet user and me, representing
a cable company, on opposite sides of the
table, literally.
Internet User Hank: First things first, for
the viewers at home I think we should just
define what net neutrality is.
Cable Company Hank: Sounds like a fine place
to begin.
IUH: So net neutrality is the idea that internet
service providers should provide access to
all of the internet at the same speed: no
matter what content it is, no one gets any
preference.
CCH: Fair definition; the question is: is
that a good idea?
Like why should I, an internet service provider,
have to provide Game of Thrones via BitTorrent
at the same speed as I provide it through
HBO Go?
IUH: I don't know, cause you're not a law
enforcement agency and that's not your job,
but like, you shouldn't be determining how
your users use your service.
It's the internet; you just provide access
to it and, but like, my concern is that if
you do it to BitTorrent that you'll do it
to, like, a legitimate competitor to your
business, like Netflix for example.
CCH: No one is talking about doing that.
IUH: I mean, you say that, but yeah they are.
Like Comcast literally slowed down Netflix's
internet connection and forced them to pay
to get faster access to their customers; like
it happened already.
CCH: Netflix is responsible for over 30% of
the bandwidth use of the US.
Why should all of our customers, regardless
of whether they use Netflix, be required to
pay for the massive infrastructure upgrades
necessary to provide that service.
Of course Netflix should pay.
But, we're not talking about slowing down
Netflix to make them pay.
We're just saying we're going to speed Netflix
up if they do pay.
IUH: I mean if you sped Netflix up without
adding any new bandwidth, wouldn't you definitionally
slow someone else down in order to speed Netflix
up?
You are, right now, for the first time in
American history, making the internet a non-level
playing field.
You talk high and mighty about economic efficiency,
but what creates great economies is not profit;
it's competition, which is what you're trying
to destroy.
CCH: I mean, the internet's a mature industry
now; we can't keep running around like it's
1998 hippie-fun-feel-good times.
It's time to buckle down and turn this thing
into a real economic engine.
We want to charge customers for access to
content and charge content companies for access
to the customers.
We get paid twice, it's great for us!
IUH: The internet is not your business model.
The internet is a massive, technological,
and economic, and cultural force for good
that everyone should have equal access to,
and your place as a middle-man does not bequeath
you magical powers to extract value at every
turn!
You have no right to decide what information
goes at what speed through your pipes.
CCH: I mean, don't we though?
We're already doing it with Netflix; we kind
of already set the precedent.
Let's face it, this is a complicated legal
thing, and with the potential upside for us,
we can afford a lot of lawyers and lobbyists.
No offense, but I don't think you can play
on our level.
IUH: I guess we'll see.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Hi.
I'm a little bit worried about this.
I want the internet to remain open and neutral
in America... for selfish and also altruistic
reasons.
You can help.
And please do; the FCC is currently asking
for comments.
Please go to comment at the FCC's website,
there's a link in the description.
Tell them to classify broadband internet as
a common carrier service, which will prevent
telecoms from making the internet a closed,
non-neutral place.
If you want to help in more long-term ways,
in the description there are a few organizations
that are working on these issues, actually
hiring lawyers and lobbyists to compete with
the telecoms.
You can give them money; you can give them
your time; you can give them your action,
and you can call your congress people.
I love the internet a lot and I bet that you
do too, and I am worried what's gonna happen
if we let the middlemen decide what the internet
is like.
Frankly, I don't trust 'em.